[Musik]
sie arbeiten mitten in der Nacht sitzen
den ganzen Tag im Auto kämpfen mit der
Bürokratie und verdienen doch oft
weniger als den Mindestlohn
Selbstständige in Deutschland ein
Stundenlohn darf sich als selbständiger
nicht ausrechnen es waren schon paar mal
die Gedanken okay macht das wirklich
Sinn für uns normale selbständige gibt
es keine Unterstützung rund 4 Millionen
selbstständige gibt es in deutschlandch
steigende Kosten und Bürokratie bringen
immer mehr in
[Musik]
Not kfeld am
niederin ÖK ist Friseurmeisterin vor 10
Jahren hat die 33jährige sich ihren
Traum erfüllt und ihren een Laden
eröffet Coron überstanden jetzt spürt
sie die Folgen der Inflation höhere
Kosten und die Kunden kommen seltener
das Geschäft führt Esra mit ihrem Mann
Akin es hast du schon geplant wegen
Montag ja wir müssen Montag einkaufen
fahren die aktuelle Wirtschaftslage
meistern die beiden mit klarer
Aufgabenteilung so wie es jetzt läuft
funktioniert das nur in der
Konstellation zusammen ja also sie ist
die operative Einheit sie macht hier die
ganze Praxis und ich mache das alles was
hinten rum ansteht Backoffice
einkaufplan meetingsplan
mitarbeiterplan für ihre Selbständigkeit
zahlt Esra einen hohen Preis lange
Arbeitstage kurze Wochenenden kaum
Freizeit selbständig heißt für mich
Verantwortung
ne also ich habe einmal im Jahr im
Urlaub und du musst halt ja sehen dass
endees Monats halt alles bezahlt du hast
verantwortungüber dein Angestellten ich
habe manchmal keine 8 Stunden Schicht
sondern ich bin sogar manchmal 12 bis 14
Stunden hier hier in Krefeld müssen die
Menschen auf ihr Geld achten die
Arbeitslosenquote liegt bei
10,4% eine der höchsten in
Nordrheinwestfalen die Menschen sparen
das erlebt Arkin östtirk in seinem
Geschäft täglich wir selber merken
das Kunden die öfter zu uns kamen ziehen
das jetzt länger die interal sinder
worden und auch die anderen Friseure
denke ich die merken das viele haben
bereits zugemacht 10 Jahre lang war hier
ein Friseursalon eine Straßenecke weiter
das gleiche Bild auch hier hat ein Salon
zugemacht hat zweii Gründe einmal dass
die Kosten steigen auf der einen Seite
und zum anderen auch die Verbraucher die
haben ja
auch Kosten und wollen halt auch an
jeder Ecke
sparen die östtürks stehen vor einem
Dilemma immer mehr Arbeit für immer
weniger Gewinn Preise anheben das geht
kaum ja also ich sage immer man muss auf
dem Teppich bleiben ne also so 3 4 €
kannst du D erhöhen aber jetzt ich würde
jetzt keine 50% auf dem Preis draufleen
das ist dann unmenschlich ne Akin und
Esra haben aber keine Wahl sie müssen
die höheren Preise ihrer Lieferanten
Zahlen hallo zusammen alleine die Farben
sind um rund 30% teurer geworden Akin
kauft jetzt öfter und dafür weniger ein
damit nicht zu viel Geld in den
Warenbestand geht Warenbestand Schätze
sich
auf 5000 € der 36-Jährige kümmert sich
um die Finanzen des Geschäftes in diesen
Zeiten keine leichte Aufgabe seit di
Jahren müssen Sie eine Krise nach der
nächsten bewältigen Zeit zum Durchatmen
hatten sie lange nicht mehr hat ja
angefangen mit der
coronakrise dann kam der Krieg und dann
auch noch die Inflation also ich schätze
mal dass wir um die 2 bis 3000 € schon
teurer sind als wie vor 3 3 bis vi
Jahren um bis zu 40% seinen ihre
Betriebskosten in den letzten 3 Jahren
gestiegen sagt Akin Energie und
Wareneinkauf sind die größten
Kostentreiber wir haben Energiekosten
Heizung Strom knapp 450 € monatlich
Telekommunikation 50 € fürs ecgerät
zahlen wir 200 € im Monat Personalkosten
in Höhe von 4000 € Miete
Material knapp 3000
€ wir müssen jeden Monat knapp zein5000
€ in die Hand nehmen Personalkosten sind
der größte Teil der Betriebsausgaben
Friseurmeisterin hylja arbeitet seit 4
Jahren im Salon doch obwohl sie
übertariflich bezahlt wird reicht nach
Steuern Versicherungen und Inflation
auch ihr Einkommen für immer weniger z.B
unser Auto ist kaputt gegangen die
Reparatur hätte sich gar nicht
gelohnt wir haben das Auto abgestoßen
neues ist nicht drin oder der Urlaub ist
ausgefallen dieses
Jahr der Tariflohn für friseurgesellinen
mit Berufserfahrung liegt in
nordrinwestfalen aktuell bei 13,20 €
brutto pro Stunde netto kommen davon
gerade mal 1600 € auf dem Konto an dafür
Vollzeit zu arbeiten scheinen man nicht
mehr
einzusehen ich kenne selber zwei Leute n
mal keinen Namen die selber diesen Beruf
auch erlernt haben die wirklich ihren
Beruf deshalb an den Nagel gehangen
haben die haben gesagt die machen das
nicht mehr die gehen nicht mehr
für das Geld noch arbeiten weil das
Bürgergeld das reicht
den da Personal teuer und schwer zu
finden ist müssen Akin und Esra immer
mehr arbeiten freie Zeit zusammen ist
sel
ich habe die Zeit eigentlich im Geschäft
mit meiner Frau und abends beim
Fernseher gucken wenn wir überhaup
Fernseher gucken ne
also wir sind halt 90% am Arbeiten haben
10% Freiheiten samstags sagen wir mal so
nach 18 Uhr und Sonntag das reicht also
ich finde das reicht nicht also doch mir
reicht meiner Meinung nach wird
das Ingelheim am
Rhein
Dekoration Haushaltsartikel Kleidung
Jens Zeller verkauft ein buntes
Sortiment der 29jährige wollte schon
immer Kaufmann werden mit gerade mal 20
hat er sein erstes Geschäft eröffnet ich
ma die gerade auf den selbständer Frau
Schweiger gell dass wir die noch
verkauft
kriegen das Sommergeschäft lief
schleppend viele Artikel wurden nicht
verkauft mit Sonderpreisen versucht der
selbständige jetzt seine Ware an die
Kunden zu bringen Reduzierung ist immer
ganz schlecht das ist man kann froh sein
wenn man dann den Selbstkostenpreis
raush hat also es hat dann einfach nur
mehr Arbeit gemacht als dass es Umsatz
regeneriert
hat beim Einkaufen schauen die Kunden
heute genauer hin das merkt auch Jens
Zeller und reduziert seine
Verkaufspreise das Problem im Einkauf
sind die Preise seiner Produkte um rund
30% gestiegen also jetzt z.B wenn ich
jetzt eine Kerze für 9 hab hat die mich
3 EUR gekostet und jetzt kostet mich 4 €
bis 4,20 € und von den 5,90 € muss ich
ja auch noch 19% umsatzsteuerzahlen und
von dieser geringen Gewinnspanne muss
ich meine Fixkosten bedienen mit den
ganzen Kosten die monatlich abgehen fünf
Geschäfte betreibt der Unternehmer
insgesamt muss er jeden Monat 80.000 bis
90.000 € erwirtschaften um alle Kosten
decken zu können doch das wird immer
schwerer in diesen Zeiten achten die
Menschen mehr aufs Geld
man bezahlt ja gefühlt doppelt so viel
wie vorher gerade bei Obst und Gemüse
und diesen Sachen und ehrlich gesagt im
Moment gucke ich viel aber kauf wenig
wenn man fragt sich dann natürlich wo
geht das noch hin wenn das war so diese
Steigerung anhält weil die ganzen
Gehälter hcken ja quasi hinterher ne die
Grundnahrungsmittel die bleiben die
braucht man ja auch aber alles andere
schränkt man schon
ein also den Kaffee draußen kneife ich
mir
oft Jens pendelt zwischen seinen Läden
oft mehrmals am Tag er verkauft verteilt
Ware berät Kunden seine Arbeit liebt er
doch immer wieder kommen auch
Zweifel wenn vom Finanzamt eine riesen
Steuernachzahlung kommt das sind so die
Momente dieses finanzielle wo ich dann
sag wahnsinn was rackert sich mein Team
und ich uns ab für so viel Steuern die
wir zahlen
müssen
nach Ladenschluss ist für Jens noch
lange nicht Feierabend jetzt warten die
Aktenordner seine Zweizimmerwohnung ist
auch Büro die Buchhaltung macht er
selbst unterstützt von seiner
Steuerberatung Lieferscheine abheften
Rechnungen überweisen Krankenkassen
bezahlen der bürokratische Aufwand wird
für den Selbständigen von Jahr zu Jahr
größer es gibt so viele Dokumente und
die müssen wir alle 10 Jahre aufheben
also ich fülle schon langsam eine Garage
habe aber keine Garage es ist bei Oma
auf dem Dachboden aber die platzt auch
langsam ja ja ich wünsche mir da echt
eine Vereinfachung des ganzen der dieser
Bürokratie ist ist der
Wahnsinn bei fünf Geschäften mit 19
Angestellten ist der Verwaltungsaufwand
extrem hoch 60 Stunden Wochen sind für
Jens keine Seltenheit 4200 € zahlt er
sich monatlich aus nach Steuern und
Versicherungen bleiben ihm netto ca 2200
€
das entspricht einem nettostundenlohn
von 8,50 € 12 Stunden Tage schlaflose
Nächte und nur wenige freie Wochenenden
und Jens muss sparsam leben Rücklagen
bilden ich könnte mir ein bisschen mehr
mit mehr monatlich nehmen aber da nehme
ich mir das Puffer auf dem
Geschäftskonto und gerade weil sich
alles verändert und die Gewinnspanne
sehe ich das zu
risikoreich seinen eigen Stundenlohn
kennt der selbständige
nicht ist ganz schwierig nein ich habe
es nicht ausgerechnet ich habe es
einfach noch nie und habe mich auch
nicht
getraut früh am Morgen in Berlin Po
schon seit 2 Uhr nachts arbeitet far
bchw in seiner
Backstube heute ist es besonders
stressig eine Maschine bringt den Ablauf
durcheinander so eine Maschine die hat
bisschen Probleme gemacht und dann weil
das ist halt so durchgetaktet dass man
sagt okay Z Uhr fängt man an und bis 6
Uhr bis die Kollegen da sind sollten die
meisten Sachen schon fertig sein der
27-Jährige hat die Morgenschicht mit
seinem Vater der arbeitet seit über 20
Jahren als Konditormeister in Berlin
mittlerweile fällt dem 63jährigen der
Job nicht mehr so leicht wie früher ich
habe mit aufstehen und nach arbeiten
habe ich gar keine Problem aber nur mit
alter jetzt langsam hier
rückenchmßen Farhad hat die Bäckerei
zusammen mit seinem Bruder gekauft damit
haben die Söhne ihrem Vater einen Wunsch
erfüllt selbstbcker zu werden stand bis
dahin nicht in seinem Lebensplan durch
mein Vater würde ich sagen okay der war
sozusagen er hat auch diesen Betrieb so
gefunden das ist sozusagen zu Verkauf
standand und dann habe ich gedagt okay
alles klar dann machen wir uns
selbständig in diesem
Bereich mit all seinen Vor und
Nachteilen das Aufstehen das ist so
einmal so dieser Moment wo man sagt so
okay scheiße jetzt muss ich aufstehen
insbesondere jetzt im Winter ist es noch
schlimmer weil man hat wirklich keine
Lust 6 Uhr Fahs Bruder um bereitet den
Verkauf vor seit rund zwei Jahren
betreibt die Familie das Geschäft
Brötchen verkaufen uma könnte sich auch
anderes vorstellen also Spaß würde ich
nicht so sagen aber mehr Halt für die
Familie halt also von daher ist es
auch eine Motivation dass es auch unser
eigen Geschäft ist in einem
Familienunternehmen müssen alle mit
anpacken um Erfolg zu
haben guten Morgen kommen Sie rein doch
ihre Backwaren werden in der Herstellung
immer teurer die Preise zu erhöhen würde
kaum funktionieren Berlin hat mit 20%
die zweithöchste Armutsquote aller
Bundesländer viele Berliner müssen
sparen meistens Wochen in Einkauf sag
mal so wo man dann die ganze Woche sich
bestückt für Kühlschrank ne etc das ist
schon spürbar ja klar ich sehe es und
ich weiß meine Tochter das ist ein fünf
Familienhaushalt drei Kinder also da
höre ich öfter dass sie da ganz schöne
Probleme die Situation bekomme ich
eigentlich jeden Tag mit d manche
Geldproblem haben
und manche wirklich so halt wegen paar
Cents dass die überrascht sind wow das
ein Kuchenstück kostet der 250 anstatt
jetzt sagen wir mal
230 wir versuchen ein bisschen
entgegenzukommen und da habe ich
Verständnis dass ich einfach Kunden auch
sogar manchmal was schenke so
halt doch ihre Bäckerei ist keine Tafel
die Familie muss mit ihren Produkten
Geld verdienen und das ist schwer es
waren schon paar mal die Gedanken okay
macht das wirklich Sinn z.B Sommerferien
war katastrophal die Brüder Arbeiten
über 50 Stunden pro Woche trotzdem
bleibt am Monatsende wenig in der Kasse
es reicht zwar für die Ausgaben um die
um das alles aufrecht zu erhalten aber
dann ist es nicht mehr sage ich mal die
Maßen sind dann nicht so hoch
beispielsweise dass man sagt okay nach
eineinhalb Jahren sollte man s weit sein
dass man sagt okay wir investieren jetzt
in einem neuen back
rufen die finanzielle Planung ist nicht
so aufgegangen wie sie sollte dazu kommt
mit den eigenen Eltern zu arbeiten kann
anstrengend
sein sehr sehr schwierig mit der Familie
vor allem mit dem Eltern da sind halt
mein Eltern so bisschen altmodig drauf
so und die sagen nein ihr könnt sowas
nicht machen was macht ihr da so das ist
zu viel Geld was ihr da investiert z.B
bei den Kaffeemaschinen da war eine
rieseniskussion hat Betrieb
Wirtschaftslehre studiert und für ein
start-upunternehmen gearbeitet für den
Wunsch selbständig zu sein bringen er
und sein Bruder jeden Tag Opfer ihr
Privatleben kommt viel zu kurz natürlich
wünscht man sich eigentlich so ey lass
uns zusammen Sport machen gehen oder was
auch immer kommt halt nicht mehr vor
also weil wir früher halt ständig
zusammen unterwegs waren Sachen gemacht
haben jetzt beschränkt sich das so auf
Wochenende seit wir mit dem bcker auf
angefangen haben musste ich leider auch
mit Boxen aufffüen obwohl das halt auch
ein Traum war irgendwo hochzukommen auch
das Familienleben ist heute anders der
ist halt nicht nur mein älterer Bruder
sondern auch mein Kollege mein Freund
und mein Geschäftspartner Halt und von
daher muss ich halt gucken wann ich die
bruderrolle Spiele wann ich die
geschäftspartnerrolle
Spiele die Übernahme der haben sich die
Brüder gut überlegt Fahad hat als
Betriebswirtschaftler Businesspläne
erstellt und finanzielle puffe
eingerechnet doch dann kamen Krieg und
Inflation Energie und Gas wurden zum
größten Kostentreiber der Vorbesitzer
der Bäckerei hat ca 2400 € für seinen
jährlichen Gasverbrauch gezahlt nach der
Übernahme steigen die Gaskosten auf rund
6000 € doch das ist noch nicht alles
und trotz der geleisteten 500 €
monatsabschlag also vorher 200 jetzt 500
habe ich eine Nachzahlung von 3800
bekommen das ist schon heftig er und
seine Familie müssen und wollen es
selbständig schaffen Selbständigkeit ist
ein ständiger
Kampf besser anstatt zu sagen ja ich
will unbedingt dass da irgendwas von
Himmel kommt und mich da rettet oder
meine Rechnungen bezahlt passiert nicht
so oft
[Musik]
montagmgen in Krefeld Esra und Arin
haben heute ihren freien Tag das Paar
hat ihren Friseursalon montags immer
geschlossen doch statt Wellness und
Erholung heißt es Wocheneinkauf im
Großmarkt eigentlich könnten beide eine
Auszeit gebrauchen doch als selbständige
bleibt dafür kaum Zeit wir gehen einmal
im Jahr zwei Wochen
Urlaub eigentlich hier gerne länger aber
das ist halt nicht
wachbar und wir waren jetzt Juni Juli
für zwei Wochen in der Türkei halt ne
überwiegen sind wir halt nur fürs
Geschäft da
ne heute geht es vom Großmarkt direkt
zurück zum Salon letzte Woche standen
Gespräche mit der Bank und dem
Steuerberater im
Terminkalender wirklich frei von Arbeit
sind auch ihre freien Tage nie
eingekauft haben sie die
Grundausstattung für die nächsten Tage
Getränke drge
ü die Ken auch dafür bezahlen Sie heute
mehr als früher heute haben wir
investiert knapp 210 € wobei das unser
wöchentlicher Einkauf ist
ne es ist ja alles teuer geworden ne und
wenn die Gehälter sage ich mal nur
minimal erhöht werden können sich halt
das ist ja Friseur ein Luxus
ne bevor die Handtücher gewaschen und
der Salon aufgeräumt werden bleibt Zeit
für einen Kaffee die Folgen der
Inflation spüren Sie täglich doch
aufgeben kommt für diese beiden nicht in
Frage wenn man da jetzt sitzt und und
irgendwie eine Fratze sieht und sagt nee
das ist alles scheiße dann kann man
direkt den Lappen schmeißen ja klar man
hat immer Höhen und Tiefen du kann ich
kann ja nicht sehen was in paar Jahren
auf un zukommen wird
ne selbstständig und ihre eigene Chefin
zu sein das war immer Ihr Traum sagt
Esra und den will sie nicht aufgeben
wenn du an dauernd Angst hast irgendwie
dich zu sagen okay heute kann es nicht
heute läuft od morgen läuft ja
irgendwann läuft nicht und dann sagst du
halt okay dann mache ich dann Cut und ma
mich dann in andere Richtung halt mal
selbstständig aber ehrlich gesagt man
fällt und dann kommt man guckt man halt
dass man wieder
aufsteht
inolfstadt Hauptbahnhof am Taxistand wet
Ding auf ihren nächsten
Fahrgast so wo geht's
hin der Kunde möchte vom Bahnhof nach
Hause gefahren werden leider wohnt er
nur wenige Minuten entfernt eine kurze
Strecke für Pauline nach langer
Wartezeit kann sich diese Tour überhaupt
lohnen nee eigentlich gar nicht weil
wenn man bedenkt Wartezeit über Stunde
für Fahrt von 7,20 € wenn man
Stundenlohn ausrechnet also und es ist
ja Brut das ist ja nicht
netto Pauline Döring ist selbständig
aber was sie für ihre Fahrten berechnet
darf sie nicht selber bestimmen Städte
und Kreise legen die Taxitarife
fest wir hatten die letzte Tariferhöhung
22 und davor 8 Jahre nicht weil die
Tariferhöhungen müssen ja genehmigt
werden und es ist damals nicht passiert
und da hatten wir auch vorher schon zum
Kämpfen nach 8 Jahren ohne Erhöhung
durfte ihre Preise um 12% anheben und
doch verdient sie heute weniger als noch
vor einigen Jahren Grund weniger Kunden
und gestiegene Kosten die nächste Fahrt
führt zum Krankenhaus nach Regensburg
mit solchen Touren versucht Pauline
auszugleichen dass die Geschäftskunden
weggebrochen sind also das was vorher
Geschäftsfahrten waren sind jetzt
Krankenfahrten bei mir es sind schon ab
und zu Geschäftsfahrten noch da
natürlich aber sehr sehr wenig also ich
sage jetzt mal 10% und vorher hat
90% Krankenfahrten sind besser als
unbezahlt am Taxistand zu stehen doch es
gibt ein Problem bis die Krankenkassen
zahlen vergehen Wochen so fehlen Pauline
oft tägliche Einnahmen während ihre
Kosten sofortfällig sind z.B an der
Zapfsäule 2022 haben die fünf größten
Ölkonzerne zusammen rund 200 Milliarden
Dollar Gewinn erwirtschaftet Geld das
auch von Pauline Döring und ca 250
taxifahrenden in Deutschland stammt vor
3 Jahren habe ich
124 pro Liter Diesel und jetzt sindmer
bei
1 70 und das sind halt schon sind ja 50
Cent pro Liter und das ist schon viel
und wir fahren halt viel und da merkt
man das schon also und das schmält halt
schon extrem der Gewinn wo übrig
bleibt zwei bis dreimal tankt Pauline
pro Woche heute ist der Tank nicht mal
voll und kostet
74€ und 61 ist das viel ja schon
eigentlich würde ich sagen so fast 20 €
zu
viel mit gefülltem Tank zurück zum
Taxistand wieder heißt es warten auf die
nächste Fahrt die Zahl der Fahrgäste
geht zurück alle müssen aufs geldachten
dieser
Tage was mich echt ärgert sind so beim
Einkaufen du stehst wirklich vor vor
Käseschachtel oder so sag das kann W
sein bleibt gleich aber es wird alles
teurer taxifahren ist halt schon
Luxus am nächsten Taxistand trifft
Pauline eine Kollegin mit Ines Peters
tauscht sie sich über ihre Situation aus
Sorgen machen ihnen fahrdienstanbieter
wie uber und die Fahrerinnen fühlen sich
benachteiligt VFT wir müssen gewisse
Sachen einhalten und wenn nicht bekommst
du deine Konzession nicht verlängert uns
wird es immer mehr erschwert und uber
hat freie Hand K zumachen weil die
Kollegin schon gesagt hab das ist nicht
auf Augenhöhe das SMer einfach nur die
Verlierer an der
Nummer schmeiß ich irgendwann Hand noch
neuen Job aktuell ist uber bereits in
deutschen Städten eine Konkurrenz für
die
Taxiunternehmen
durch Inflation Steuern und Abgaben ihr
kaum mehr Geld bleibt als wenn sie
staatliche Leistungen beziehen würde die
Arbeit muss noch ein Wert haben sie muss
irgendwo auch geschätzt werden ich meine
ich gehe hier für 12 € und paar
zerquetschte in die Arbeit und andere
sitzen zu Hause und haben aber dasselbe
Geld wenn sie wenn ich runterrechne nach
Abzug meiner ganzen
Kosten nach einer Stunden Schicht kommt
Pauline nach Hause am Rande von
Ingolstadt wohnt sie zusammen mit ihrem
man
gün Feierabend hat die 56-Jährige aber
noch nicht wie jeden Abend trägt sie
ihre Fahrten ein und erledigt die
Buchhaltung ihre Geschäftszahlen kennt
die selbständige genau wir sind schon
wieder von Umsatz sage ich mal auf den
Niveau vielleicht wie vor Corona aber
vom Gewinn sind wir weit weg weil ja die
Kosten so gestiegen sind ich habe jetzt
den Umsatz so wie vorher aber der Gewinn
ist um
30% bis 4%
weniger was das konkret bedeutet sieht
sie jeden Monat auf ihrem Konto von
einem durchschnittlichen Monatsumsatz
von 4000 € blieben ihr vor Corona brutto
ca 2000 € Gewinn heute sind es bei
gleichem Umsatz nur noch brutto rund
1400 €. ein weiteres Problem die
gestiegenen Zinsen also ich muss mir
jetzt ein neues Taxi kaufen weil ja mein
altest Getriebeschaden hat also ein Teil
muss man immer
finanzieren ich bin fast von die Socken
gefallen ich habe meine Hausbank
angerufen D hat sie gesagt im
zweistelligen Bereich sind wir bei einem
Kredit mindestens 40 Stunden arbeitet
Pauline pro Woche nach Steuern und
Versicherungen bleiben ihr ca 1000 € pro
Monat zum Leben bleibt wirklich also
wirklich wenig es es ist
so es ist es ist wirklich nicht es ist
nicht einfach und dann überlegt man
schon aber ganz ehrlich ich bin 56 wer
nimmt
mich aufgeben will Pauline nicht auch
weil sie ihren Job gerne macht
stattdessen wird gespart
Restaurantbesuche sind selten und
Urlaube kurz 6 Jahre ist die letzte
längere Reise hier da waren wir da 14
Tage mal weg also das war das war der
letzte lange Urlaub nur wirklich nur
kurze Urlaube wo möglich
sein günthering arbeitet in der
Bauaufsicht einer Raffinerie mit beiden
Gehältern können sie gut leben sagen sie
aber wie es später mit der Rente wird
wissen sie nicht natürlich dass man
irgendwann sagt das reicht dass man sagt
man kan jetzt dem wohlverdienten Ruhe
standand geh wo bei der Selbständigkeit
nicht so einfach ist bei mir kommt
irgendwann mit Sicherheit rund 90 000
selbständige haben 2022 ihr Geschäft
aufgegeben ich bin ja
Einzelunternehmerin find dass das
ausstirbt mit der Zeit weil sie es nicht
mehr lohnt oder weil man die Entlohnung
nicht bekommt was man eigentlich
bräuchte und das ist
schade Jens Zeller ist noch weit von der
Rente entfernt er ist selbstständig und
wollte es nie anders ich glaube meine
Eltern seitdem ich mich erinnern kann
habe ich die schon immer über einen
eigenen Laden genert mit 29 betreibt er
mittlerweile fünf Geschäfte der Preis
der Selbständigkeit ist aber auch dass
er seine Familie kaum sieht dass er
liebt seine Schwester immer wieder ja
ist natürlich schon schwierig wenn man
ihn mal erreicht hat schnell schnell ich
komme später wir müssen es verschieben
ich krieg auch oft ich will nicht sagen
Vorwürfe aber schon mal gesagt hier es
wäre schön wenn wir jetzt zusammen Zeit
verbringen dass die Arbeit jetzt mal
Nebensache ist aber es fällt mir so
schwer weil wenn ich dann einen Anruf
bekommen aus dem Laden was jetzt meine
Antwort bedarf dann denke ich wenn ich
jetzt nicht drangehe und die Antwort die
notwendige liefer dann habe ich morgen
Dilemma im
Laden stress und berufliche Belastung
machen sich auch gesundheitlich
bemerkbar wenn ich die letzten Jahren
krank war war das oft auf Stress
zurückzuf zurückzuführen meine
Hausärztin hat schon lange mit mir das
Gespräch gesucht dass ich mich
entschleunigen muss ich habe immeresagt
ja ja aber mein Körper gibt mir andere
Signale und dann war da sowas wie
kreisruner
Haarausfall Gürtelrose war alles schon
dabei Jens Vater ist stolz auf das
Geschäft seines Sohnes aber die Zukunft
als selbständiger macht ihm
sorgen die Gedanken und Sorgen trägt man
als Elternteil mit ja das ist leider so
und ist schon Verantwortung was trägt
und die Gedanke die Zukunft Corona
überstande ja also denke ich das wird ja
auch funktionieren das wünsche ich mir
auch alles gut
geht für die Familie ist wieder nur
Kurzzeit denn im Laden wartet bereits
ein Mitarbeiter auf Jens die aktuelle
herbstware wird heute
fotografiert um Kunden in seine
Geschäfte zu locken betreibt Jens drei
Social Media Kanäle auch für ihn wird
online marketing immer
wichtiger z.B heute morgen haben wir die
Kerzen ausgepackt und die können wir
heute abend morgen früh schon auf
Instagram zeigen und gerade durch die
Inflation durch die geringere
Gewinnspanne müssen wir ja auch mehr Gas
geben also sind wir mal ehrlich muss es
ja irgendwie auch wieder kompensieren
diesen
einnahmenverlust dazu kommen hohe
Belastungen durch Steuern und
Abgaben Einkommenssteuer für
Selbständige oder die Umsatzsteuer die
hatten wir ja temporär zu coronzeiten
für ein halbes Jahr gesunken bekommen
das hat uns auch sehr geholfen aber
damals war Corona und jetzt ist die
Inflation und jetzt sind wir auf uns
allein gestellt
ja allein in der Krise soühlt sich die
aktuelle Lage für Jens und viele andere
selbständige in Deutschland an ich wir
gut also ich hoffe dass die nächsten
Monate sich vieles klärt weil ich jetzt
wirklich an dem Punkt bin wo ich sag
jetzt ist nicht mehr gerechtfertigt die
Preise aber ich dann auch hoffe dass
irgendeine Botschaft an die Politik
kommt dass wir da auch eine Veränderung
spüren und Unterstützung sie investieren
viel arbeiten hart und verdienen immer
weniger selbständige geraten durch hohe
Kosten Abgaben und die zunehmende
Bürokratie immer öfter in
Not